When we need to study something in science
that is too large or complex to easily work
with, we’ll often make a model of it in
order to recreate it in a simpler way.
You might not realize it, but we actually
use models all the time in our everyday lives.
They can be static and representational, like
the New York City subway map – or they can
be used to make predictions of dynamic systems,
like a weather forecast or the ups-and-downs
of the stock market.
Even our understanding of climate change,
a phenomenon on the tip of everyone’s tongues,
is based on predictions made by climate models.
Global Climate Models, otherwise known as
GCMs, are gigantic computer codes of mathematical
representations of our Earth’s climate system,
and they are generated based on the laws of
physics.
Let’s take a look at how it works.
Energy enters the atmosphere as solar radiation,
which then transfers and circulates within
the earth's system. To track how the energy
flows through this system, GCMs try to simulate
the earth’s climate conditions. They account
for processes such as solar inputs, the heating
and reflection from the land and water, the
movement of air masses,
and ice-albedo response.
GCMs divide the earth into thousands of gridded
3-D cells. Each grid box holds a single value
of the atmospheric variable such as winds,
temperature, pressure, humidity, cloud cover
and cloud ice that is being predicted. In
the past thirty years, due to advancement
in computational power, the size of the gridded
boxes has been reduced, and the mathematical
equations are more accurately solved.
As the earth is divided into discrete cells,
so too is time divided into finite intervals,
or time-steps. If we want to compute quickly
the global climate in 10 years, we might be
tempted to do it in one go, with a time-step
of 10 years. Such a large time-step is impossible
though, because the energy we are accounting
for within a cell would have moved on into
adjacent cells. Movement of air, for example,
is a factor that may only need a small time-step
of 30 minutes or less. So instead, GCMs take
an initial climate state and calculate the
climate state one time-step away, after which
they repeat the calculation with the resulting
new climate state. This is repeated until
the total number of time-steps reaches our
desired target time of 10 years.
It might seem like there would be lots of
room for error in so much processing, but
think of it this way. When we flip a coin,
it is hard to predict whether the result will
be heads or tails. However, over many flips,
we can reliably say that the probability of
a heads is 50%. GCMs have time-scales that
are decades long, which means hundreds of
thousands of time-steps, or coin tosses. Because
GCMs simulate the earth’s climate over large
time-scales, many consider GCMs to be robust
in comparison to shorter time-scale models.
To test the GCMs, scientists have gone back
and used the models to recreate climate history.
This way, they can compare the models’ predictions
with actual empirical evidence recorded in
the past.
They started at 1900, and attempted to predict
the climate changes over the next 100+ years
– a century in which an unprecedented spike
in temperature occurred.
They ran the model twice: the first time,
they only included natural forces. The second
time, they included human factors in the equations,
accounting for the increased addition of greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere .
Comparing the observed global and regional
climate data from 100+ years, the first round
of GCMs predictions didn’t match up. But
when the models ran the second time, accounting
for both natural and human factors affecting
climate, the results were incredible. Not
only do the predictions lie within a 95% confidence
interval of the actual data, but they are
correct for both the continents and the oceans
individually. And it wasn’t only one GCM
that found this to be true – the results
of every single one of the 15 independently
run GCMs agreed.
This allows scientists to attribute the climate
changes they have observed to human factors
such as increased industrialization, deforestation
and urbanizations which lead to an increase
in the concentration of greenhouse gases.
If you’re still skeptical, let’s take
a look at another example.
When the first sophisticated GCMs were developed
and run in the 1990s, the predictions they
generated didn’t seem to make any sense.
They indicated that there would be a rapid
heating of the upper layers of the troposphere
and a corresponding cooling of the lower levels
of the stratosphere.
But when the recorded data from 1960 onwards
was examined, it turned out that the GCM’s
predictions were verified. The cause was,
once again, the effect of greenhouse gases.
These gases, concentrated in the troposphere,
were trapping low frequency radiation -- causing
the unexpected warming of the troposphere
and the corresponding cooling of the stratosphere.
So even though not all models make correct
predictions every single time, the GCMs have
proven over and over again to be reliable
and sophisticated systems. And if the past
is any indication of the future, we would
be wise to heed its predictions.